bella a tutti i ragazzi benvenuti a
questo nuovo video bello di happy meals
quel gioco di chi mi ha rotto le vecchie
cuffie ho dovuto cambiare le grossi
nicchi se volete fare delle tinga nichi
box lascio il solista grameen
descrizione sto scherzando ovviamente ti
voglio bene kylie bahrami le cuffie ti
prego sono sono finito l'uomo cavallo
senza testa va bene sono tutto ai pato
con la madonna
ma come può veramente che figo ma hanno
fatto livello bellissimo updown non for
words ok largo ho detto l'ex co credo
che sul movimento ci siano nei problema
ecco è secca e la e vabbè ho capito o no
no non sono migliori di tassi non mi
ricordo non mi dicono non fa niente a
posto tutto bene buon halloween a tutti
è già passato halloween di se ne frega
però averne un paniere salve madonna che
livello e ditelo subito nobel
bellissimo dato la mia testa in staccata
cielo in mano come non mi è caduta loro
sono veramente questo livello è molto
carina mi piace soprattutto so definire
questo gioco
questi tre mesi dopo un po di tempo che
ci gioco posso finalmente definire
questo questo veramente dedurre che
questo gioco adatto a tutte le famiglie
compresa la nonna dove stiamo andando
esattamente mia volata una gamba vela
regalo è halloween la fine una piccola
autobiografia è diventato proprio parte
della letteratura questo gioco poco
fight pixel art
ma anche figo sono tutti i nemici pixel
ma cove scriptor ma che figata è però
non è che mi fa
scusate mi devo testarla sarò ma non mi
fa mi stanno facendo male o sbaglio
[Musica]
sbaglio ricordate i ragazzi non testate
mai la potenza di squirt all perché
potrebbe essere un problema questo
tenetelo a mente che magari vi salva la
vita
supermario porca vacca questa di fitch e
bull fix mio dio
ma come sapete che superò le sto a pisa
giorgio reference cia lizard e ho vinto
molto carino se devo dire la verità un
po pixelato ma aumentare la grafica
problema ramble boltro finalmente un
boltro arcobaleno facciamo una roba
anche colorata su streamit che finora fa
tutto molto tetro se andiamo sulla morte
non ci credo sono vivo tavoli cielo san
secondo sulla volte sono uno sfigato
perché siamo davanti come faccio a
beccare la sua beccando subito jackpot
proprio contento di aver fatto jackpot
guarda facciamo nella prossimità non
facciamo jackpot cosa dite ragazzi
andiamo su vittorie basta per favore per
cortesia al bambino non mi serve però la
lancia lo stesso
no non è il soggetto ho capito in al
jackpot lo comprendeva il tronco
semplicemente la palla mi è andata
ancora è successo
cos'era web gmg oggi vorrei andare su
vittoria teoricamente è unicamente non
sono capace mortal kombat fammi vedere
cosa sei riuscito a creare cavolo e
proprio realistico mortal kombat non ci
aveva voglia di farlo però l'ha scritto
poteva scrivere anche kakà fu buche era
uguale bottiglie aiuto no è un livello
veramente difficile da sembra una cagata
ma vi giuro non lo è allora fermi
no no no è solo caduto a va bene fa
molta come ti faceva cadere indietro non
mandiamo su mortal kombat ragazzi che è
meglio parco a demonio marco ragazzi è
veramente difficile se non so come fare
sta roba
cioè il primo sono cagato sotto
è il primo avvolto la dove trovo
veramente un sacco di difficoltà ragazzi
cè un casino vero win per favore non
arco demonio porco win per cortesia per
cortesia va bene
o provino a posto com'è possibile che è
successo j pop per ora come così può
morire non riesco a vincere
ragazzi ma scusatemi ma com'è possibile
gen quattro anni andare o e pronomi p e
monete e non vale
quante ce n'erano la scusa ragazzi non
riesco a vincere non riesco a vincere
neanche col tronco che mi toglieva meta
meta al traguardi tre palle poi vabbè o
ce l'ho fatta due ore ci ho messo tutto
veramente la che ci ho messo due ore a
far sorridere l'incredibile vabbè
andiamo avanti ragazzi ride speedrun pd
non è una roba fatti denunciati
proprio di no vai di sotto di sotto di
sotto di sopra di troppo e torino sono
vivo sono vivo tutto bene tutto a posto
devi riuscire a non perdere se non
prendi la sedia teoricamente dovresti
teoricamente però sono spaccato ha posto
grande
tutto bene
fatemi let's do air france benissimo
sono contento moderni
a distanza di 163 episodi con una giacca
ancora tutto a posto kilic parkour credo
sia una roba non mi piace su uno laser
luca signor luca ho visto un subliminale
viso l'enigmista proprio la e vabbè che
cosa fare a c'era una bomba
c'è una bomba dentro il coso io devo
staccare mela senza farle esplodere ok
non è proprio facile perché lui poterci
riuscire
devo fare piano praticamente alle figo a
[Musica]
mi scusi
sto livello è fatto benissimo tra
l'altro come si apre la porta mi scusi
arrosti posso entrarci dentro casa da tè
orc caput vacca mi è esplosa la mia devo
capire bene come non farla esplodere per
gli effettivamente è un pò sensibile fra
la macchia mente malata degli averi per
farceli mentre sta roba lascia perdere
la morte della zia aiuto piano ok giorno
giovanna questo cagando sotto c'è una
sciali no questo no questo no me lo puoi
fare questo non me lo puoi fare come
passo non passo più ce l'ha fatta
non so come sia possibile ti prego ok a
posto tutto bene tutto bene ma come le
scale come le scale non ci posso fare i
passati sulle scale no ragazzi un ansia
e non posso andare di sopra come vado no
ragazzi un anzi incredibile questo
livello è veramente assurdo madonna c'è
un'ansia faccia uscita all ascensore
mi scusi lei cosa sta facendo qui esco
di qua esco come la chiave l'ora trovo
dove la trovo parola trova sicuramente
c'è la notizia mi scusi a una chiave lei
serve mi serve una chiave si faccia
puntellare bene bene perché io avendo
visto tutti i soli l'enigmista ciò che
le chiavi stanno nei corpi quindi
teoricamente la chiave li scusi ma
potremmo andare avanti e non lo so ma
devo saltare per forza ragazzi qua muoio
ma devo saltare perché non ci arrivò mai
o vado di soft ma non certo si sa che
salto si sa che non salto sono morto
ma ci provo adesso è vero è impossibile
come passa voli
vabbè è stato bellissimo però ben fatto
veramente bene
non so come sia possibile veramente una
figata per sedute sei malato soul kinky
però bel livello contro ragazzi per
davvero
togliamo po di tensione perché se no
allora lui che ha scoraggiato addosso va
bene uk e tanto e non è la cosa peggiore
che hai fatto in questi anni lei va bene
time machine crusade o è di che fine hai
fatto spiare cavi cos'è sta roba
poi l'inverno sta arrivando è anche
nonno ciak
questo non lo dicevano per questa nostra
dissi ma morte non saprei come spiegarlo
va bè ragazzi facciamo questo cuoco
bellissimo che mi sembra quello fatto
veramente meglio non è vero cenacolo di
halloween che la pazzesca brava betsy
con le cose di prima voler cogliere
senza testa andiamo avanti
[Musica]
per le terre del nord posto non lo so io
non ho visto che mostrano subito citando
cose a caso era stato non solo studiato
però mi sono molto divertito mi piace
fare yoga in questo modo qua
ragazzi questo era april premi sia
piaciuto ragazzi consensi è piaciuto suo
momento e completi piace anche per i
social che come non invitato dalla
descrizione schiacciate il tasto
iscriviti la campanella preso la
giornata i suoi video e noi ci vediamo
appunto ad un prossimo video beh ragazzi
[Musica]